why the packers restricted after a few
days of
camp the ability of the beat writers to
put out information about who's starting
who's getting first team reps what the
rotations are who's in what packages
because the fans aren't there it isn't
as open as it normally is there won't be
the preseason games
so the rules allow all teams to be more
secretive to hold their cards closer to
the vest and
goody coons made the decision hey look
everybody else is doing it or at least
others are doing it it's hurting us to
not do it
and the league's allowing it shireen
that's the bottom line in this crazy
upside-down year
i know that it's not something that the
media likes because it makes it harder
for the media to do its job
but i understand where the teams are
coming from because they're trying to
ultimately construct a roster
and a practice squad with the best
possible players based on the best
possible information
and if there's a way to limit the
information that other coaches and gm's
have about their team they're going to
do it
yeah look mike i was in a lot of these
negotiations is a
board member for the pro football
writers of america
and it goes way back these coaches
wanted nobody at
practice this season during training
camp
because they said the fans aren't there
we got coveted using safety is
in health as as a reason to keep
reporters out so we went from no
reporters at practice
to hey we're going to have two pool
reporters like they do at the super bowl
practice to all right we'll let 10
people in there
but it's going to be a team by team
decision on what gets out
and every every other coach in the
league is going to see what the packers
did if they haven't already they are
right now
seeing what the packers have done with
limiting what comes out of those
practices i guarantee you
32 teams now are going to say there is
going to be nothing coming out of our
training camp it's a different training
camp because there aren't fans there
and practice rules will change once the
season starts so they really just have
to get through the next three weeks
and then we go back to regular season
rules where reporters are only there for
the first 30 minutes and they don't see
anything anyway so
yeah they they want to restrict as much
information as possible
they're doing that green bay isn't the
only situation we've seen we've seen it
in atlanta and seattle have kind of
clamped down
in dallas we saw the mccoy injury gerald
mccoy goes down and the reporters aren't
allowed to report that and nfl network
comes out and reports it during practice
here's the reason why i think these
concerns may be overblown by the teams
that are clamping down on the
information
pay attention to the patriots beat
writers there's no restriction on what
they're putting out there
so if bill belichick doesn't see a
benefit or if he sees strategically
his best move is to allow this
information to be out there in the
public consciousness
maybe it's not something that the
packers and the seahawks and the cowboys
and other teams should be worried about
because if it's working for belichick
maybe it should be working for them as
well hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports